[Music]
you know I have to ask you about this
you had an embarrassing technical snafu
that occur in your life last year I know
you've talked about it a little bit but
you I'm still trying to understand what
happened you tweeted out a topless
picture of yourself accidentally mm-hmm
and I'm just real curious how that
happened
it's a fascinating story involving not
knowing that my new BlackBerry have a
touchscreen mm-hm and responding to
somebody on Twitter like oh yeah New
York was great it's 9:30 on a Wednesday
awesome
apropos of nothing here my boobs so you
had a picture of yourself on my phone
that didn't come with the phone that's
on all new blackberry they're in trouble
they need something so you had one of
these pictures one of these pictures on
my phone because I had been away from my
at the time fiance and we had spoken on
the phone the night previous and anyway
the next morning I was sitting see that
is the thing that's the thing I still
can't wrap my brain around is and I know
I all the younger people on my staff are
always like oh my phone got stolen I
better find it because I've got all
these pictures and there's no picture of
me naked my doctors never seen me naked
you don't have like a weiner kind of
picture not a wiener I mean an Anthony
Weiner style his photos
I mean it out all it is I've got them
free but no I don't it's just a yeah I
don't know I mean it's it's a dumb thing
to do I suppose and now I've I've I've
realized just how dumb and and and so
embarrassing so hideously embarrassing
that for about three months after it
happened I couldn't any time I met a new
person I just wish I was like boobs
nice to meet you you see my boobs yeah
it's not even the case but and so but
but I also think it's becoming so common
and I mean I don't know I just think the
President and everyone running for
president in ten years there's gonna be
naked photographs that's definitely true
and I can't wait it's a horrifying
vision of the future
[Laughter]